I am honored and humbled to have been
chosen by the Conservative Party to
become its leader I would like to pay
tribute to the other candidates during
the election campaign and I would like
to pay tribute to Andrea LED s'en for
the dignity that she has shown today I
would also I would also like to pay
tribute to David Cameron for the
leadership the team during during this
campaign my case has been based on three
things first the need for strong proven
leadership to steer us through what will
be difficult and uncertain economic and
political times the need of course to
negotiate the best deal for Britain in
leaving the EU and to forge a new role
for ourselves in the world brexit means
brexit and we are going to make a
success of it
second we need to unite our country and
third we need a strong new positive
vision for the future of our country a
vision of a country that works not for
the privileged view but that works for
every one of us because we're going to
give people more control over their
lives and that's how together we will
build a better written thank you